il reste neuf secondes dans ce dernier
quart temps versailles et châlons reims
sont dos à dos dernière possession pour
les espoirs rémois les versailles et
doivent défendre pour créer l'exploit
dernier rebond favorable à chalon
versailles s'incline 80 à 83
ouais ça fait mal parce que j'aurais
préféré perdre de 10,15 points plutôt
que que comme ça sur un dernier tir
vous savez c'est toujours embêtant de
perdre les deux équipes sont vraiment
venu pour jouer cette équipe c'est une
bonne et jeune équipe elle est bien
entraîné il était vraiment préparé pour
gagner le chesnay versailles a débuté ce
match avec un avantage de 21 points face
au jeune espoir de châlons reims équipe
évoluant en pro à des événements de
tenter de maintenir cet écart mais les
approximations techniques face à la
vitesse des rémois permettent aux
visiteurs de revenir à un point des
versailles et 47 à 46 on avait à coeur
de montrer vraiment une meilleure une
meilleure prestation que ce qu'on avait
fait en première mi temps où on avait
perdu beaucoup de ballons et on avait un
petit peu tergiversé sont nos choix
après voilà
en deuxième mi-temps on a eu un sursaut
d'orgueil ça nous a pas permis créer un
gros écart même si à un moment on est
encore à plus 8
soutenu par un public venu en nombre le
chesnay-versailles resta auteurs
présents au rebond au contre et avec
plus de réussite aux tirs et versailles
et reprenne mais huit points d'avancé à
trois minutes de la fin du quatrième
quart temps le score 80 à 73 et on était
prévenu on savait qu effectivement ça
est une belle équipe avec un secteur
intérieur dominant enfin seb et les très
bons joueurs avec également de
l'expérience plus de maturité
cette maturité va permettre aux joueurs
du chesnay versailles de rebondir en
championnat de régionale 2 après cette
première défaite de la saison